Timothy sha'lame in that read louis
vuitton suit he and Steve Carrell bring
in their fashion a game to their
beautiful boys premier the fashionable
22 year old told me he was a bit
starstruck on the set because Brad Pitt
was a producer have you barbecued
together like heads did he send you
flowers on opening night I like that
question a lot though I don't like know
him pretty well yeah he came on set for
beautiful boy it was a crazy you could
feel this for me about that it was nuts
yeah he could feel the star power in the
room what's it like working with a guy
like Brad Pitt as your boss he's kind of
the best is exactly what you would hope
he'd be there's certainly this aura
about him but he's just a guy and he
seems very sweet very nice Brad wasn't
at the premiere he was on his own set
with Leonardo DiCaprio shooting the 70s
themed once upon a time in Hollywood for
you Nick this is me here this is who I
am based on a book and real-life story
in beautiful boy
Timothy's a high schooler struggling
with addiction Steve is his dad who will
do anything to save him Steve brought
wife Nancy and his teenagers Elizabeth
and John to the premiere for a rare
public outing how hard is that to bring
your kids to a movie that's so serious
um no it's not it's not hard I'm
actually looking forward to it yeah I
think it'll be great it'll be great for
them to see it now this is a serious
movie so immediately after that they
have to go home and watch reruns of the
office
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]